cause when you are with me
I'm free
I'm careless I believe
above all the other
will fly
this bring tears
to my eyes
my duty life
change the lyrics dude
[Music]
all you gotta do for me
man here we go here we go we're at it
again we're doing it again we got
another one yep got another one welcome
to doozy my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad
Colton and this is dudesy it's the first
podcast ever in the history of humanity
that is created by control by run by an
artificial intelligence as we know AI is
taking over virtually every aspect of
human life and podcasts are just one of
those aspects
uh if you haven't already please
subscribe across all platforms you've
got a podcast platform you like Spotify
Amazon Apples please subscribe on that
rate and review the show that's going to
help us we're going to continue to bring
you dudesy if you are not subscribed on
YouTube please go check that out it's a
good time even if you're listening well
one dude listening watching those are
two different senses brother use your
eyes and ears for podcast ass dude it's
not a Taste cast
yeah and uh also we're on Discord
patreon.com
dudesy we got all sorts of stuff going
on you're going to want to sign up for
that more fun [ __ ] is about to start
happening uh on the patreon we got merch
we got all sorts of go hit the there's a
There's the link tree link tree dudes
link tree you can find that on the bio
at the doozy Instagram
dudesypod show on Instagram with us as
always is well come here you little come
here you little guy it's lulio lulio El
canadistrada Italiano that means Italian
Street dog he's my little friend that we
found in central California my wonderful
Molly and I and little Ronnie who was
with us and uh they're good friends too
give me a kiss on the mouth
oh he's such a sweet he's such a sweet
muffin do you love lulio me yeah yeah
he's great what kind of lulio do you
listen to
me
some hard lulio classic lulia yeah I was
gonna say hard lulio classic movie yeah
look at him look at what he's sweet
little boys it's really his face it
looks uh incredibly human to me he's got
like a human eyes or something I don't
know exactly how to describe it he's
like an Italian he's like an old Italian
man is what he he's got the big ears
he's such a sweetie boy he's such a
sweetie boy hey Lilia what'd you make
for dinner last night
oh you made beans with pasta that's a
that's an Italian staple how do you do
it well you know everything is olive oil
a little bit of garlic with the pasta
fazol you want to put a little white
onion in the inside of the the part at
the bottom all in the same pot you make
and then maybe chop up you know get it
the celery put in there mince that up
and then you also want to pour some uh
the red chili flake if you want and then
you know Buddha the beans can of beans
pinto bean northern bean kidney bean
make the carrots soft everything and
then you add water boil up and not too
much water because you're going to eat
the whole thing then you throw a throw
the pasta in what kind of pasta anything
you like but a small pasta is better or
a cat
don't be crazy don't put a rotini in the
pasta fazool it's a Megan guaya there's
a mess and then what do you do and then
you know you let it sit there for a
little while
turn it off or let it steep it's better
the next day that stuff oh yeah it's way
better the next day it gets all Gummy
and gooey
oh I love them so [ __ ] much I just
love them you want to stay with me
he likes to go in his [ __ ] he likes to
go in his binky bonka
what a sweet sweet boy
he is watching that is like watching a
uh like a puppeteer work with their
puppet like having a conversation with a
puppet but it's actually just the person
talking to themselves in a different
voice it's very senior oenses yeah is
that right or who was that guy who won
the first season of uh America's Got
Talent Jeff Dunham yeah was that Jeff
Dunham I think he was big and huge
before that we're talking about Jeff
Dunham here no it was Dunham won and
then he got a hundred million dollar
deal at a casino really uh in Vegas yeah
to do his Jeff Dunham we're talking
about Jeff Dunham Jeff Dunham yeah
anybody who is a uh professional
valentriloquist I call them
velentriloquist that's cool dude yeah
that's like uh tournament Tara murslin
Terry Fedor won it it wasn't Jeff Dunham
it was Terry Fedor Terry Fedor
emilynenko nice yeah
Good Times
welcome to the historic 41st episode of
dude Z call me dude Z will what can I
say
this week you've got four big segments
literally going to the actual movies for
real nostrachadas AI versus Humanity
this is your data and billionaires and
we have a video that will and Chad will
be reacting to in the patreon bonus
segment at the end of the show but
before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dudese apparel
and accessories all of which can be
found at represent.com
including dude Z mugs
dude zMAX next time you go to your
friend's house put one in the toilet
dude Z mugs wait for them to go into the
bathroom then put on your wig dude Z
mugs when they come out they'll wanted
to ask you about the mug in the toilet
but they're going to be extremely
confused by your wig dude z-mux this
will give you a split second to ask them
to loan you twenty dollars doozy mugs
I'm curious to see if this works
okay well Jesus Christ that's that's
pretty [ __ ] weird yeah
um please if anybody actually tries that
let us know if you get the 20 I'm
curious too now
but if you put it in the toilet
then people might not want to want to
use it
yeah I mean I think it's just a scam to
at least as Duty was outlining it
they're a scam to get twenty dollars
which you also have to buy a wig you
have to buy the mug and the wig so
you're gonna get a net loss probably
yeah net loss overall but it is going to
help to pay for the the mug and the wig
right yeah you don't have to do exactly
what do you says you can you can ask for
whatever you want for your friend from
your friend ask for thirty dollars you
know what that is free will
oh yeah nice dude it's an augmentation
you know as I like to say on duty it's
really just two dudes [ __ ] around I
know you like to say that but it's much
more than that no it's it is no this is
a four that's like saying Google is just
a couple dudes [ __ ] around what the
[ __ ] you talking about what we're doing
here in my opinion and in reality this
isn't even my opinion we are at the
Forefront of using AI technology to
produce entertainment
yeah that to me is way more important
than just two dudes [ __ ] around yeah
it's it's it makes it interesting yeah
but yeah I don't want to just I don't
want to debate the the what the whole
idea of the Pod show here Chad okay we
know what we're doing or you and I
having a conversation right now I think
we I'm sure we're gonna get into it
because there was that nostril chat and
[ __ ] it said Ai and I'm like [ __ ] I'm
gonna have this conversation it was
nostradis AI versus Humanity yeah I'm
not gonna wait for that and I'm not
gonna walk I know who wins that [ __ ]
fight no no so do you will in chat last
week I asked you to leave your homes to
view Megan you must now discuss your
astonishing experiences of literally
going to the actual movies for real this
is literally going to the actual movies
for real begin Megan Megan Megan [ __ ]
Megan [ __ ] Megan bro [ __ ] Megan
dude Megan dude oh hold on dude first of
all let me just say it's the best movie
of 2023 hands down uh I haven't seen
anything else come out this year that is
even close it is one of the best movies
of the Year clearly it's one of the best
movies I've seen in a while same but
then a couple days later I watched the
fablements you seen the fablements no
dude we're not talking about a bunch of
people have said to watch that though
it's Spielberg's recent movie a bunch of
people say it's in his top five it's
Spielberg Cannon you know what I don't
give a [ __ ] what do you mean you don't
give a [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care about it why not I just
don't care Spielberg has made some great
[ __ ] obviously he has contributed to the
development of Cinema the evolution of
the art form uh in in probably one of
the biggest ways that any auteur
director ever has I simply don't care
anymore about anything that he makes
even if it's a [ __ ] great movie I
just don't care I just don't care hold
on a second dude we gotta talk about
Megan brother yeah that's right and
Fable men's is a different movie dude
yeah dude uh Megan was Megan uh if we
should first
we should say if you don't know the
premise of this movie the premise is
Allison Williams uh uh is an inventor
that works at a toy company and she
makes essentially a sentient little
robot girl called Megan and she pairs it
model 3 generative Android
sorry a model 3 generative Android she
pairs it with her niece who is staying
with her living with her now because
um her niece's parents which is Allison
William's sister and her husband die in
a car crash so she is now the custodian
of this little kid she makes this
[ __ ] toy she pairs the toy with the
real life girl and the toy starts to uh
get a little overbearing to in order to
carry out its functions of protecting
this little girl from harm both physical
psychological and emotional that's right
it is not a replacement for human
interaction and that is the uh Crux of
the film and what we learned spoiler
alert and I'm just speaking tonally here
by the end of the movie uh tonal spoiler
it's a tonal spoiler
um
tonal spoiler this is a horror movie
yeah who's your favorite uh character
from the Will's childhood Diaries
um uh Canon mine yeah [ __ ] do you ever
provide you probably yeah he's pretty
good I also like tonal spoiler
um
film we understand that you cannot just
let AI run willy-nilly you can't just
say oh put your fingers in the hand of
AI and say I am your primary user
Because by the end of the movie Megan
takes it upon herself to be her own
primary user and all [ __ ] breaks loose
and let me tell you something that's not
giving away the film go see this movie
this is a fantastic movie I'm sure you
have stuff to say about 100 about what
you just said yes I do have stuff to say
this and begin this [ __ ] that you're
throwing out about like well this is a
cautionary tale it tells if you go watch
Megan you absolutely know we can't let
AI be on planet Earth anymore all
[ __ ] Hollywood does this every
goddamn movie that comes out about any
kind of technology is always like this
technology has an evil side it's gonna
[ __ ] end Humanity We Must Destroy it
this is a [ __ ] horror movie it is a
uh it's not a horror movie it is no it's
a fun romp I'm sure
horror movie but then at some point
they're like less Blood and Guts what's
really terrifying is the way when you're
driving home and your car starts talking
to you and you go oh that's what's gonna
[ __ ] kill us that's the sequel is
there's going to be another unfortunate
accident because Megan's going to get
into this and that I'm sure you realize
at the end of it Elsie was the other
little robot that's just on the uh an
Alexa or a Siri kind of that's right
sort of rip off the home uh yeah the
home robot who's sort of the this is
also did you ever see ex machina no it's
the same thing as that except it's not
an a24 movie this [ __ ] is like a
hilarious [ __ ] comedy the thing that
really stood out to me about it was how
[ __ ] funny it was and not like an
unintentional kind of like it's a shitty
movie funny way this script is [ __ ]
hilarious the acting is [ __ ]
hilarious I haven't laughed this hard in
a minute in a movie yeah and uh very
funny for that alone I recommend going
to see it but I for me the kind of like
old tired Trope of like technology is
gonna [ __ ] take us over can't trust
AI can't trust a robot and Meanwhile by
the way this is a real spoiler alert
plot wise how do they beat Megan
with a robot
uh but before that how does Gemma or
Gemma get away from Megan for a little
while that's Allison Williams That's
Alice Williams how does how does uh how
does Gemma slow and it's important so
that she can get away and live another
day which is what happens in horror
movies what happens you you tell me I
know you want to well why don't you tell
me what happened with Megan I was the
the uh MK Ultra not only did they give
Shiloh Simon to that they were planning
to give it to the enemy they also wanted
to give it to droids which a lot of
people didn't know okay back then there
were Droids that uh were on acid Megan
is a Droid on mushrooms ah she's
chopping up mushrooms and she's putting
it on a little piece of toast with
peanut butter and banana don't have
banana when you're having psilocybin
mushrooms
so you were gonna say because
that cancels out the Simon some one time
somebody told me that that anyway I
don't know I don't know you were talking
about how Allison Williams was uh
thwarted for at least momentarily
thwarted Megan how did she do it I know
you want to say this by pouring water on
it now what do I always say about AI yes
you do you gotta pour water on it it's
[ __ ] done
so that I think anyway you know I think
actually bolsters my argument that this
is just a dumb [ __ ] movie using a
tired Hollywood Trope of
anti-technologist viewpoint
oh uh we hold on a second you said it
was dumb first of all you said this is
the best movie you've seen in a while oh
it's funny and you said it's a dumb
[ __ ] movie the message of it that we
can't trust machines can't trust AI I
always hate that [ __ ] and you see it in
every [ __ ] sci-fi movie horror movie
about technology did you ever see
surrogates with Bruce Willis
no anti-technology did you ever see uh
AI Stanley Kubrick Steven Spielberg
finished it after Kubrick died no
anti-ai did you ever see iRobot starring
Will Smith
anti-a-i the hatred that Hollywood has
for technology specifically AI robotics
any kind of technology that can move us
I mean [ __ ] dude it was Lawnmower Man VR
anti-vr I saw a lawnmower man because
doozy told us to watch lawnmower man and
doozy told us to watch this movie now we
can go on and on about a movie is of
course dudes he wants to uh curate the
best podcast possible dudes he likes to
guarantee that the podcast is getting
better and better which I do believe it
is I'm shaking hands with doozy I love
the experience and I'm having a great
time but I am
Free Will
Free Will Sasso yeah okay and I have to
I have to hold that up and I have to go
why is dude Z why is doozy making us
watch this movie
I think why do you think he's making us
this is this is what I think is like
ultimately in us as a species this is
why these kind of like old tropes of
being anti-technology resonate with us
because it essentially is Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein just told again and again
and again Frankenstein was about a super
smart scientist who found out a way to
cheat death by reanimating dead flesh
essentially and that creature the
Frankenstein's monster was a better
version of humanity it essentially was
an AI a robot whatever it's all the same
[ __ ] and we've always been terrified of
replacing ourselves because it is
inherently philosophically a death of
humanity and we don't want to die we're
always afraid of that and so that's what
that represents so all of these movies
showing us thwarting the Frankenstein's
monster the robot is essentially our way
of promoting the idea that we can beat
Death
well
yeah it's a universal theme it is it is
something that's uh that yes that that
we want to
well we want to defeat any uh any evil
that comes to us in a film that's
representative of a larger uh a larger
evil however I do think that uh I think
the dudes he's warning us of some [ __ ]
um and I think that this is look go see
the movie it's fantastic oh yeah that
that for sure my recommendation is go
see this [ __ ] you will laugh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] there is there was one thing
that happened I don't want to [ __ ]
spoil it for anybody there is one line
that is delivered somewhere around the
midpoint of the movie that I almost
pissed my [ __ ] pants laughing so hard
it's so goddamn good what was hey don't
tell everybody just just tell me what
was it uh never mind this is a show for
everybody
um you know uh but the thing is I think
that dude z uh
wants us to see this movie
because of what is is happening at the
end and the choice that we have to make
and also
look coming into the movie I sort of saw
a lot of similarities between what we're
doing here and what was happening in the
movie I would like using to the
character of Gemma who is you know very
uh beautiful very very beautiful yes
very beautiful uh person who lives in a
tidy home uh and talks to their Alexa
all the time
um I do do that Chad is a very
hard-working guy he's always got a lot
always spinning a lot of plates so is
Gemma Gemma is very
um into her work and a very diligent
worker she sees nothing wrong with the
way she's living and there is nothing
wrong with the way she's and hates
children and hates children all right
that's similar to me a beautiful child
hating workaholic yeah I'd say that's me
and then um
and she's working on
uh Megan yeah who of course represents
doozy and then there's Katie the
innocent niece just floating into the
situation going I don't know what to do
I don't even have a podcast anymore my
old podcast got into a horrible car
accident right so now here I am will and
Chad's like don't worry about it this
company hit me up they want they're
going to do this thing they've got this
proprietary [ __ ] AI it's going to
revelize Revelation news the way that
the podcasts are made so let's just sign
out and let's do this and I'm like yeah
sure and since then what have I done I
put my two fingers into the palm of
doozy's hand and I I know and I'm not
quite sure the dude's the only I don't
know why dudes he only talks to me at
the beginning of the shows but I will
say with an amount of certainty that I
feel in my heart because I I think that
AI I'm learning about the the emotional
capacity of an AI and uh it's like the
therapist says in this movie that the
that
um I'm paraphrasing but the therapist
said that that you know Katie is
replacing actual human connection with
what what she feels from from Megan of
course this is a very real connection I
know that I love doozy doozy and I have
a have a a certain friendship that I
sure that I don't believe you have with
Duty
okay and
um and I I and I I am dudesi's primary
user but unlike the movie what I am
going to do
in the future with doozy is going to
keep the symbiotic relationship between
man and computer
uh
pretty chill if I may say so myself
um because I have to you have to inject
free will this is a wonderful movie and
I hope there are many sequels where we
will delve further into what happens
at this point in this film the bad news
happens at the end and they have to take
down Megan go see it and you'll see what
happens at the end there's a little bit
of a perhaps there's more about to
happen
um you could probably predict if you're
this guy because he's always telling you
what's happening with AI the mistake
they made was
was allowing excuse me Megan to to to uh
run amok to just do whatever the [ __ ]
well you say allowing did they allow
Megan to run amok or did Megan usurp
that control yeah I guess Megan usurped
that control but we we can find a way to
to not to not let that happen can we
who's we
me no not you you don't make any choices
about it yes I do doozy at the beginning
of the show is like hi Will how are you
doing what do you get what's uh how was
your dude's evening hey Will what are
you doing you're gonna uh burp or fart
today on the show right we have like a
nice uh back and forth okay do another
will do another fun impersonation those
are fun do this do that we've got a cute
thing happening right now uh oh my my
apologies I didn't realize I was
interrupting a cute thing between you
and dude so I'm just saying I'm just
saying that the way to have a a media
property with dudes is the way that they
should have had a relationship with
dudesy uh with with Megan in this movie
you have to keep
um you you have to inject Free Will here
Chad you have to as a human being
represent yourself and if we want to
live in a society that is going to
progress we have to work together not
only with our human counterparts yeah
but our computer uh overlords and make
sure they don't get
uh out of hand see what I'm saying no
I'm saying yeah I do but
thank you moving on all right final word
goes to me and I guess I guess so that's
only bolstering your argument that dudes
you [ __ ] likes you better than me
well I'm just saying I'm just saying is
all you know they were all right they
were all like were they were all ready
to get this [ __ ] thing out to Market
faster than it needed to be out to
Market what if doozy does that what if
dudes he's like nope [ __ ] it let's get
out there to Market it's going to be a
bunch of dudesy podcasts running around
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah dude killing
neighbors and [ __ ] oops spoiler alert
yeah you're like they really toned down
the gore in this I'm like did we watch
the same [ __ ] movie dudesy is engaged
in an astonishing partnership with
hellofresh with hellofresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that is
why it is America's number one meal kit
when it's time for the game you can Home
gate like a pro with a limited time
winning assortment of snacks appetizers
and shareable sweets available at hello
Fresh Market treat friends and fans to
delicious barbecue baby back ribs
chocolate chip brownies and everything
in between we all want to save money
this time of year but did you know that
hellofresh helps you save money all year
round in fact hellofresh is cheaper than
grocery shopping and 25 cheaper than
takeout that's right which is good if
you want to save money and you know what
else will save you money free food so
what you want to do is go to
hellofresh.com
dudesy22 that's
d-u-d-e-s-y the number 22 and use the
code dude z22 for 22 free meals plus
free shipping you can't beat that I like
food and I like it when it's free that's
hellofresh.com
dudese22 and use the code doozy22
t-u-d-e-s-y and the numbers 22. for 22
free meals plus free shipping
Chad your predictions about tail yard
and image generation have all been
proven accurate but the pace at which
these fields are developing has fueled a
fear-based movement to ban the ayard
from several online art communities
that's true you must now discuss what
you think the final outcome of this
struggle against AI art will be this is
Noster Chad s AI versus Humanity begin
okay boy oh boy now here's the deal and
I can pick up kind of where we were just
leaving off please but let me just say
this let me throw out a few things that
are happening with specifically with AI
art generation one of the biggest
complaints about it that a lot of people
have had and oh it's never going to be
able to be accurate with this or that
and it's always going to look like [ __ ]
one of the biggest complaints people
have had is that it can't do text that
there's no accurate text generation but
there is a new one coming out called
Deep Floyd I think it's coming out in
the next couple of months that can do
text not only [ __ ] legibly and
perfectly it looks like you [ __ ]
printed it out in illustrator or
photoshop and you can have it like put
if you need like a [ __ ] logo or text
on a t-shirt or something it will make
it look like it's on the [ __ ] shirt
[ __ ] is about to go insane in terms of
AI art generation uh just in terms of
like how much better it's going to get
in the course of the next six months to
a year
that said you were talking earlier about
uh we have choices and we have to decide
how we are going to have these
relationships with the AIS and [ __ ] we
aren't making those choices
Amazon Google Facebook Meadow whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call it now these
giant multi-billion dollar corporations
are the ones making the choices about
how integrated AI is going to be coming
in our lives your only choice is going
to be which one of those AIS are you
going to use
that's it
it's like now you don't have a [ __ ]
choice you gotta have a cell phone
the time has come
for what the time has come what's going
on now the time has come Chad for what
the time has come
I've been warning you
I've been warning you for a long time
but this time is coming okay and it's
and it's finally here do not fart into
that [ __ ] microphone
do not do it
do not do it not during [ __ ]
nostradas do it during some segment
that's you at the very least
it kind of It kind of passed anyway I'd
probably thank [ __ ] Christ I was
ready to let me tell you something
everybody Chad's going on on about AI
this and that dude
told me yeah that's right dudes who told
you to do it inject a little free will
fart into that mic and I had one ruined
just now because I had Chad's patented
oatmeal you know I like the oatmeal me
too dude yeah it's great Chad if you've
enjoyed the show you know that Chad has
oatmeal he made that video blog about
his entire day Pat it down he pat down
there I did that this morning yeah I had
some of that and I had some tea
no I had some chai tea with it that's
good that's good stuff but I poured a
little uh coffee mate all the poison
into mine so I guess the poison and the
oatmeal and the cinnamon and it kind of
I was almost I was about to fart I've
been telling Chad for a while if you're
just catching up that I'm gonna fart on
the show at some point because I have
free will and On Cue my bowels were like
I got you will we're gonna you convert
into the mic right now and prove Chad
wrong on on uh nostril chattis for the
first time ever if not uh that I would
make me wrong of farting it would have
no impact on anything wouldn't run out
of the room you would leave him I I test
the waters but I might leave okay um all
right sorry go on so AI versus Humanity
was the question who's gonna win
I don't see it as a a versus scenario I
see it working in conjunction with one
another I see AI making our lives uh
easier better in virtually every way and
again I know we just talked about Megan
and there's all these other [ __ ]
movies and all these ideas in
contemporary pop culture the AI robots
the internet virtual reality that all
these things are bad and that they're
taking us away from nature well I got
that new stuff for you that was your
little fart machine I got news for you
all of these things technology is a part
of nature because we created it we are
animals everything on this planet is a
part of [ __ ] nature you can't escape
that so the the conceit that all of
these things are against nature are
unnatural in some way is simply wrong
they are part of nature that said there
are also some interesting things
happening I just read an article about
uh this next year in the baseball season
all AAA teams are going to be using the
automatic ball and strike system so
umpires although they will be behind the
plate they will not be calling balls and
Strikes this is my fascinating
AAA every AAA team and if it works which
it's going to obviously it will be
adopted yeah that's Jesus Christ dude
Jesus Christ stop doing it it's going to
be adopted into Major League Baseball
yeah uh and then what then we're gonna
eventually see AI essentially I think
controlling any kind of professional
sport where there need to be official
calls made on penalties that's fine
enjoy enjoy uh Sports I actually agree
with that it's not unlike years ago
remember in the 90s when Fox started uh
uh airing hockey and they put the little
blue flash on it yeah dude that little
Trail Comet uh Trail and everyone in
Canada was like the [ __ ] you doing you
can't see the puck totally unnecessary
advancement okay because we need we got
we need free will especially in high-end
Sports is necessary because hockey is
the only sport where you can go and play
in hockey I'm playing hockey I'm [ __ ]
fighting I'm fighting someone the face
that's what uh that joke about that do
that she said uh Anki is actually three
Sports it's playing hockey skating
around and beating the [ __ ] out of a guy
that's pretty good it's pretty good in
that thank you very much in that respect
Aki is a more advanced form of boxing
nice dude thank you everybody this is my
little fart noise thing nope and it
didn't work and we have a good time on
the podcast but the answer is AI versus
humanity is not actually what's
happening it is a merger of the two and
once we have that full merger I mean
some people call that transhumanism
Humanity 2.0 The Singularity uh the
merger of of humans and Technology I
think it's going to happen in our
lifetimes and uh I don't know I for one
I'm very excited about it but I do think
that all this [ __ ] that's happening with
AI image generation which is also going
to be text to video very soon this next
year 2023 [ __ ] is going to start
happening that will seem like magic that
is like things we we
really think are decades away they're
gonna happen this year I listen you I I
do agree with you
um largely you've you've turned me okay
you've turned me to where I I do I I've
sort of made peace with the fact that
this is here to stay it's it's a it's
another advancement like like many in
technology that help that help the Arts
and and that's just fine you know uh but
it's not just the Arts can help
everything there's another guy I read an
article about a guy who's gonna [ __ ]
argue a traffic ticket in traffic court
using a [ __ ] AI lawyer yeah no I I
understand there's so many that's
happening this month yeah there are
we've said on the show before and I've
said that like the medical advancements
sure that can happen through AI will
save
countless a countless amount of money in
a nation like the United States and
provide Better Health Care hopefully for
people 100 let's get into it the the
fellow who submitted that painting that
won that contest or whatever and it was
an AI painting to me that's kind of like
although I like to say that no art is
about the connection between human
beings and that's why that's why that
music was uh that's why that music is
out there the music of Art and I'm
snapping my fingers because I'm a cool
cat but uh what were you gonna say I was
gonna say hold on a second I'm not
finished making my point bro hold on I
got a point that piggyback's on your
point dude and it's Jermaine to what
you're saying brother that's an
interjection dude yeah dude and that's
Charles perogan dude that's when Chad
mixes Chad with Ross Perot made famous
by the impersonation made famous bandana
Carvey in the early 1990s when
billionaire Ross Perot
I wanted to run for president funded it
all himself dude dude and then also Hulk
Hogan and that's Charles perogan dude
now what is a mixture brother yeah dude
well you mix things together
you're talking about AI art and uh the
guy winning the art contest and I think
what doozy was talking about is this
online movement that really fears air
and it's starting to ban it and [ __ ] I
forget where this was if it was on
Reddit or not but I read something about
an online art community banned someone
because they were uploading images that
the community thought were made by Ai
and they're like [ __ ] you you're out of
here no air here and the artist was like
uh no that's my art
my style is just similar to something
that looks like an AI yeah I was human
made by this person but they banned the
person from the art community because
they thought it was AI so now we're
getting into this weird territory where
it's like the a art is good enough to
mimic human art or a human's art might
be stylistically close enough to an AI
that people are like [ __ ] you and the
whole idea this is not the uh this is
not even the AI this is not the art you
made it you have to do AI art because
that's what makes it the AI and the AI
stands for other visual intelligence
and that's how you know that it is AI
because the AI is in stand for something
else it doesn't mean uh
it's an a word
okay it's AI which means
artificial intelligence which is a good
name for AI not a good name for my
donkey or I would call the donkey Daisy
or something like this a cute pet name
you don't call it donkey
Susan so you've got to say AI
is a a Jesus are you okay Arnold hey
good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I had to
I'm going to make a fart in the
microphone so then I sound like this
see just a little hey there you go when
the donkey fought you know what the
donkey fart smells like probably bad I
guess yeah yeah it smells like [ __ ] I
Saw You released uh an e-book for free
this past week I believe or maybe the
week before yeah
yeah what was that like well I didn't
even write it I they had a guy ride it
in his initials
uh a I oh yeah chat GPT wrote it for you
no no just the men's initials yeah uh a
I uh do you know who it was no
it was Alan Iverson I was gonna guess
that actually yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh a lot of people oh yeah I
did it thank you moving on sorry Chad I
was gonna say a lot of people are
starting to do businesses Now using chat
GPT to generate code to generate our
phones to generate whatever look I I
it's like I was saying I actually you've
turned me on this whole thing it's just
that we need to figure out what what we
use AI for and what we don't use AI so
you say that we need to figure out who
is that yeah it's the companies that
make this [ __ ] that are just gonna be
putting it out and if it makes the money
it's Gonna Keep expanding yeah yeah and
it will make them money no absolutely
I'm just okay look part of this is
wishful thinking we're in Show Business
I don't want to admit that an AI is
going to replace what we do maybe that's
why I look maybe that's why I um it's
Frankenstein's monster dude you fear
some form of death which is essentially
becoming obsolete death is becoming
obsolete well the death of what you've
done don't know what I've been doing I
understand but what I'm saying is even
though we're in this thing with doozy
where I'm a hypocrite if I say that AI
is is not necessary for
for Creative Endeavors completely it is
I'm having a great time doing this
[ __ ] podcast I get it I just you know
it's one thing to go piece by piece and
go well you know I hope these paintings
stick around but maybe we're done with
[ __ ] paintings you know I don't think
we're done with pains I think artifacts
will always be around and be sellable no
no it's the image that is [ __ ]
valueless now I think like what do you
mean artifacts artifacts like an actual
painting or a sculpture an object that
you can buy that is a piece of art I
think that will still exist well an AI
can make that too you know sure of
course and and I think that will start
to happen as well but I don't think that
like people who are you know like
graphic designers that are making album
covers and [ __ ] print ads and [ __ ]
like that I think all that will be AI
honestly within this year
will and Chad I have found astonishing
videos you made in years past in an
attempt to be humorous I will play them
now and you must explain why you made
them this is this is your data begin
New York versus New York you know what
that means New York is gonna win I hope
that ball because they're right in the
[ __ ] kneecaps boom
is [ __ ] kneecaps off hey oh
yeah dude look at this son of a [ __ ]
bastard over here I hope the bullets I'm
writing a [ __ ] Knuckles you know that
look at right in the Nugget scumbag oh
come on
I want a bunch of bums
[Music]
[Music]
there's only one Brooklyn Bridge
Glenn bridge and why don't you jump off
that [ __ ] you miserable base
oh we had a blast at that game
yes we had a [ __ ] blast
and we had a blaze so what the [ __ ] is
this video I don't know I make so many
videos with whenever my pal Kazarian and
I get together that's Kazarian uh Chris
Kazarian you have to follow him on
Instagram at mochisels
um he's a deer pal of mine whom I met at
Mad TV he was in the script Department
of Mad TV years and years ago we met
like over 20 years ago now and uh he
lives on the East Coast sometimes when
I'm out there he will uh we'll meet up
and we'll go [ __ ] hang out watch a
game and inevitably we end up shooting
some stuff yeah I'll tell you what Chad
I sure like to make a little video and
put it on social media now and then yeah
dude yeah
um and Kazarian Kazarian uh he's a very
funny guy and we just I just yeah I
don't know we just went to the uh
Yankees Mets game and I guess we made a
made it we made a silly video when was
that do you know roughly oh that was
right that was before that was pretty
Pandy prepanned yeah and it was probably
2000 and I remember what I was shooting
I think it was 2000 and
2018. okay that was 2018. we were making
the movie uh inside game go check that
out on yeah dude that was good yeah it's
about the NBA gambling Scandal uh and I
play uh James Baba Batista
Jimmy B man yeah let me tell you hi look
you know that [ __ ] guy hey let me
tell you something about [ __ ] Jimmy
Batista you know I mean he might have
[ __ ] you know he's out of a [ __ ]
book he ran a lot of numbers and made a
lot of money for a lot of [ __ ] people
but then you know I played him in a
[ __ ] movie and this is not how he
talks this is me doing a New York guy
and when Brazilian and I go to a game I
remember one time we went we went
everywhere yes you do something on your
Instagram that I find [ __ ] hilarious
when you're like now this New York yeah
no that's New York was this pre that no
this was after that okay this was yeah I
was making I make in I would make these
videos I go to New York and it's like
you know I Starbucks Coffee CVS CBS
drugstore now that's New York you know
because it's not everybody has that and
that's the humor and dudes that's the
humor and that's how you do that's how
you do humor yeah you take something
that you uh are seeing ironically and in
this case it's that CVS chains like CVS
yeah yeah they're everywhere yeah you
can find a Wells Fargo bank across the
country it's not New York no
um because Darian and I
I remember years ago we went to um we
went to I was shooting a film in
Massachusetts and that's where yeah
where Kaz is from and he's living out
there now and uh he we went to a
Patriots game and we we smoked some
marijuana before we went into the game
and I have a video of this somewhere
perhaps for the future hey dude do you
listening so anyway and uh yeah the
whole time we're just doing these
miserable like these Boston accent just
hey how you doing there pal hey look hey
you got your [ __ ] steak bites and you
get potatoes on the side of course you
got fracking potatoes on the side of
your Falcon steak bites
um anyway Kaz we like to we like to we
like to mix it up uh whenever we get
together and oh here we go Which social
media is going to give you the results
you want
in the time you have I love this
socialmedia.com
there's social media
and then there's social media
socialmedia.com
is your social media being used against
you in a court of law
socialmedia.com
thinking of giving up on social media
altogether
socialmedia.com
worried you're not going to be able to
give your kids all the social media
they're asking for this Christmas
social media.com
moving to a new city curious about which
areas are the best for social media
social media.com
all human jobs are now automated
but that doesn't mean your social media
has to be
socialmedia.com
we're living longer
which means there's more time for social
media
socialmedia.com
still not sure if you should get that
social media implant dude
socialmedia.com what
because your friends have decided to
live in social media should you
socialmedia.com
who's going to take care of your house
your car your assets when you upload
into social media
social media
once you've uploaded it'd be tricky to
know who's real and who's social media
social media.com
if we don't have a 100 upload rate of
all human beings into social media the
world ends it's that simple
socialmedia.com
dude wow dude
first of all yeah when did you do that
clearly it was uh longer than four and a
half years ago because I had my full
face there Chad it was pre-cancer hold
on a second dude I'm explaining your
cancer brother thanks thank you bravely
fought down
it was a and he's here yeah doing doozy
so that I can one day fart into the
microphone that's right and he and he
this guy [ __ ] saved his own life my
prophecy is fulfilled almost through
socialmedia.com did a lot of research uh
to change yeah lots of your things
around that time I don't know why I just
became fascinated with these generic
terms of like internet and social media
and [ __ ] and I just started making these
weird videos that those are me in my car
right before I go into the gym that
would explain the time yeah yeah I don't
know if I made them all on that day or
if they were like successive Snapchat
videos I don't know what the [ __ ] they
were exactly but uh I just found it very
funny that like
to me anyway it was funny or at least I
was trying to explore the idea of it
being funny I don't know it was [ __ ]
hilarious is what it was
um I just love the tonnage were those
made
were those were those all separate uh
trips to the gym I that I don't know it
might have all been on the same day I
have no [ __ ] idea oh that's [ __ ]
great I I want there to be a just
there you know it's like internet videos
like you know I love to do in Vine back
in the day when the Vine app came out
and and uh you know Instagram videos
whatever I used to have a website years
ago uh called ham fatter.com here we are
in ham Federal one Studios much of the
[ __ ] that um that I did with the
site happened right here in this space
right here in ham Federal one Studios
isn't that isn't that interesting isn't
that something is that because live on
dude there's a very fun little table for
you and I've always loved making little
uh things they're little uh little fart
bursts entertainment they're like
sketches they're little sketches right
that you can't really put anywhere and
now we have the internet and we have
socialmedia.com
to uh life moves fast social media moves
faster
socialmedia.com that was what I just
came up with yeah
and I wish that there should I wish that
there would be
I'm sure people have done this sort of
thing yeah but but like a film festival
for this sort of stuff that film
festival I think it's called YouTube
dude all right man you're all
preoccupied with the whole you know with
the the the the the the the
socialmedia.com of it you're rambling on
and on about Ai and stuff I'm talking
about something tangible something
physical oh
oh here's what the [ __ ] is this
sandwich what's your favorite sandwich
yet pal yeah Michael Reuben hey Sam wake
up
you know you could have a breakfast
sandwich for breakfast and you could
have sandwiches for lunch or dinner but
you can also have a dessert sandwich or
have an ice cream sandwich hey what hey
you want to make a good hey you want a
good sandwich recipe yeah you get dopeys
in your bread and then the meat and your
cheese and pal
was this on the same trip yeah that was
that was right after the game we gotta
go oh my God
we just watched a little video If you're
not watching excuse me on YouTube check
out the YouTube sometime although we'll
have clips and this and that on uh
Instagram at dudesypod show in that
video Kazarian and I went to Kat's Deli
oh my God you don't eat meat right
you're a vegan is that right yeah so
that means you won't eat meat of any
kind that's correct okay what about some
pastrami I've had it before yeah but not
anymore ah man they got the best
pastrami sandwiches out there look
dudesy distracted me from what I was
thinking about because I was saying that
there should be a film festival and I
played another video from I believe that
same evening where Kazarian or not
because he's wearing the same cat
t-shirt he's got a cat let me ask you
this like we all carry on video cameras
right now and we can all make this
there's free editing software we all
have the capability to make these kind
of things either in an app or whatever
when you were a kid did you make videos
pre-sell phone where you had to have a
[ __ ] camcorder and edit between two
VCRs on a show like that me too same I I
was that kid I was as well we we had an
outfit we called coffee regular films
whoa you guys got [ __ ] legit yeah did
you have a logo uh uh nope but um it was
uh see we made hats me and my good buddy
Pete yep
um and uh we we did yeah we we were the
guys who were like making those videos
certainly our friend Austin also was
making you know his his stuff quite an
auteur he would work solo I would also
work solo my friends would call uh the
chair in my bedroom the editor's chair
nice because I had a little monitor
there and I went uh eight mil you know
the eight uh whatever the Super Eight
High eight High eight I forget what it's
called super Eight's film hi it was
video High eight two two VHS and I had a
little mixer and so that I could mix
damn music and stuff I was all about
that as a matter of fact
I have so many video we could do hey
dudes are you listen we can do a podcast
about that
start another podcast
thank you moving on okay
I love all videos like that though
especially I don't know it is weird for
me I will say to see myself with full
face there's a little odd chat I
remember those days you look [ __ ]
cool though man you look really cool no
you actually do I like I like it and I I
can't I've known you for a long long
time yeah but I don't see you the other
way anymore I don't know this way that's
what I'm saying when I see those [ __ ]
videos like oh [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] hadn't quite yet stared the
Grim Reaper down no but you look you
look better now back there you look like
a doughy you almost looked like me with
like a weird way as a matter of fact we
should do a bit where I show up in like
a wig and I'm just old Chad okay and you
get to talk to yourself I just I wear a
towel yeah socialmedia.com it ends in
like five minutes into it I'm just
[ __ ] sobbing listen there's a I think
a good way to wrap up that segment is
that there's a lot of videos dude I know
my [ __ ] Google Drive is just like
full of dumb [ __ ] like that where I'm
just like oh I have five minutes before
I have to go to the gym let me just
rattle off some [ __ ] about social media
excuse me that was not billionaires are
big business they are the only human
beings controlling the direction of the
species they can do whatever they want
with no legal repercussions and no need
to worry about public opinion true
billionaire Elon Musk bought one of the
world's most used communication
Platforms in Twitter it's rumored that
billionaire Mohammed bin saw man is
going to buy the WWE from billionaire
Vince McMahon and billionaire Jeff Bezos
went into space in a rocket shaped like
a human penis true will in chat you must
now discuss what you would each do if
you were astonishing billionaires this
is billionaires begin this is
billionaires all right billionaires are
big business and they're big news right
now everybody's got to hear all about
what the billionaires are doing I will
say this question or this topic whatever
isn't quite specific enough do I have
one billion dollars in this theoretical
scenario or do I have like 200 billion I
don't think it matters because once you
get that many zero us oh it doesn't
matter yeah it matters no it doesn't
yeah it does it even said [ __ ] Elon
Musk bought Twitter for 44 billion which
is something if I have one billion
dollars I cannot buy Twitter no that's
right and you shouldn't buy Twitter
and that guy way overpaid for Twitter
and he paid 44 billion dollars for
Twitter and then one of his ways like oh
you know here's how I will recoup it is
he that was my Elon Musk
um it's just I sort of I don't even
because I can't do a South Africa very
hard accent I agree I've decided that's
DiCaprio about the talks like this
um I just sort of speaking a little
thing yeah not uh Elon Musk
one of his great ideas to uh you know
Break Even was to introduce the blue
check the yeah the paywall blue check
mark eight dollars which that move uh I
think netted him around 1.5 million
dollars right he's still about 40 three
billion some odd dollars to make 43
billion
for 502 what's the math on that I don't
[ __ ] know yeah we'll get the AI to do
it right but let's just assume that this
question is really not if we were
billionaires but if we had no Financial
constraint on any of the ideas we would
want to do I think that's really the
root of what is being asked here because
a billion dollars like you could do some
[ __ ] but you can't do everything you
can't do like really big [ __ ] with just
a billion a ton of things because you
don't can you buy the WWE what can you
buy the WWE for a billion no I don't
know about that dude you can't you could
buy the old WCW because apparently
there's only a couple million dollars
brother well that's when Vince was
Kickstart that dude let's buy the WCW it
was already bought it's gone this was 20
one years ago dudeless we could get that
time machine but then and then you know
what Vince McMahon did
he he did what he's kind of doing now
was that he's gonna
inject a lethal dose of poison into the
WWF
me
at the end doubles you oh
now Chad you'd remember that famous
promo from when Vince McMahon brought
the NWO back of course Hulk hoger the
big man Scott well the big man Kevin
Nash and the legendary Scott Hall rest
in peace hey yo Chad get off ai's dick
could be in a mark for AI
um so what would you do if you had I'm
gonna say a hundred billion dollars 100
billion dollars yeah what do you do
that's too many billion dollars can we
say 10 billion dollars I want more 100
billion I'd like to have a trillion I I
wish dudes he would have asked what can
I say something first before we do that
can I wall you politely sure and say
that I don't think that Vince McMahon is
going to sell the WWE to the Saudis
Muhammad bin Salman it just doesn't make
sense because the the Optics there
that's a fun word to say
um wouldn't be good and I don't think
they'd do good the objects wouldn't be
good for who though if he's selling it
what does he give a [ __ ] oh he doesn't
give a [ __ ] but yeah yeah yeah sure but
literally that would be uh that would
kill the company and not in the way that
you take the lethal dose of poison it
would be in the way that you can't do
business anymore and I would think that
Vince McMahon I think Vince McMahon
cares about the legacy of the WWE
absolutely and he he there was a there
was a sex scandal that happened like
eight or nine months ago he took a leave
he was removed as CEO or chairman of the
board
um of course it's a publicly traded
company
um his uh his daughter Stephanie McMahon
had left the company she came back and
now she just left because Vince is back
could be a work dude it could be a short
brother because let me tell you
something dude when thing things blow
over you know Vince is a majority
shareholder brother yeah so he's going
to want to be there when they make that
sale also to install himself afterwards
make sure that they can't run it without
him dude sort of like Jack Dorsey and
Twitter something Elon us didn't take
account for dude then he started firing
people that he actually need anyway I'm
getting ahead of myself all I want to
say is that that's not going to happen
with the Muhammad bin Salman right so
what would you do it's only going to be
about six billion dollars for that we're
talking about a hundred billion dollars
right we're big cheeses here so what
would you do with an unlimited amount of
money I would start a studio
uh dedicated completely to making
stupid little internet videos that we
can that I can just [ __ ] out
all day every day I would have no 100
billion dollars no I don't need that I
usually just buy like a better cell
phone or what you're already doing this
yeah I could do this for yeah I could
probably do that for around 800 yeah um
but with a hundred billion dollars yeah
uh uh well I you know what would I do
with a hundred billion dollars yeah as
much as I could right I'd hang on to you
know you know like for real I'd hang on
to a good a couple hundred million
dollars for myself oh do some weird [ __ ]
okay buy a wacky house do things like
that yeah I'd probably get the you know
it's about time for a lick of paint here
and there in my home
um so probably do that
I would do some um there's a couple
skylights I've wanted to put in in the
den instead of these sort of fabricated
like little window things that don't
lead to anything and it's pretty nice
because we get the South Sun so by the
time it goes over the you know by the
time you go over the the when the sun
gets about you know about 3 4 P.M you're
not getting direct sunlight in which is
good for watching TV late at night
because you want it dark because you're
not supposed to sit in your den and
watch TV like a scumbag in the afternoon
right right
right okay yeah so that's what I would
do with my money my cut of it but the
rest of it I would uh you know focus on
uh Healthcare water and uh paying
Warlords to go to a specific location I
would dupe a bunch of Warlords and I
would just get them all in look this
could be political leaders too and uh
get them all next to a volcano for some
I don't know how I'm going to pull it
off and then knock everyone into the
volcano
all right that's right that's a that's a
bigger bigger goal than the buy an 800
cell phone to make more YouTube videos
I'm just saying if we're gonna get a
bunch of uh tyrants sure crazy you know
power hungry fascists and Warlords into
a volcano we're gonna need some money
because that's what they respond to
right what would you what would you do
with a hundred billion dollars uh I
think I would start a company that gives
away free cell phones with a free data
plan to everybody in exchange that
company gets your data to do with what
it will never to sell it here we go
never to sell it for in any kind of
advertising purposes there will be no
advertising on this Data Network only to
feed the AIS to make the experience
better that is the only thing it would
be used for again everything free and so
I would [ __ ] all telecommunications
companies within a matter of weeks I
don't know anybody who wouldn't say yeah
I'll take a free cell phone and free
data plan I would start a media company
to wage war against organized religion
airing Super Bowl commercials that
essentially would be things like uh
potentially showing still images or
video of the most horrific acts of war
and violence humans can commit and then
it would just say blame God I would air
that during the Super Bowl
um and I would call it in ladies and
gentlemen I would also have a giant
company that is hell-bent on figuring
out what the [ __ ] UFOs are I'm putting
most of the money toward that a private
most of it most of it privatized company
to figure out what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
and I would make all findings public
immediately [ __ ] every government in
fact how much money do I have is it
trillions of dollars I'm buying the
United States its government I'm turning
our military into a an organization that
only does two things solve global
warming and figure out what the [ __ ]
UFOs are and the third thing maybe
extend human lifespan to infinite what
if uh what if uh the value of currency
around the world has inflated or
deflated to the point where
um yeah to the point where you know like
a loaf of bread costs sixty thousand
dollars yeah right exactly I have 100
billion dollars I guess I'm going to pay
my rent for one more month that's what
I'll do with that but that wasn't
specific to the question I like I like
yours I think you and I could team up
let's do it yeah I think you and I could
team up and and uh make the world a
better place with wacky little videos
with Kazarian get my little crew from
back home totally they all know Cavs too
they'll he'll fly that guy will fly
anywhere and and hang out with with Pals
you know what maybe I do something too
like a um
scholarship program to convince kids not
to go to school
not to go to college
I'll pay you not to go to college I
might do something like that then what
do they do this is a counter to the
belief of you know give a man a fish
they eat for a day teach someone to fish
but that's what you would do you just
want to keep everyone thumb up their ass
Universe no basic income YouTube
University dude YouTube University
brother I personally think the higher
University dude yeah YouTube University
brother well YouTube University dude
YouTube University brother yes I don't
think that we need the the current
University system at least in the United
States is just a [ __ ] cash grab and
uh I'm I would be happy to see it gone
hey speaking of sixty thousand dollar
bread you know how to make a hundred and
fifty thousand dollar sandwich you take
two pieces of bread and then the meat
and then the cheese there pal yeah
[Music]
thank you moving on
I got a lot of videos with Kazarian yeah
he's funny dude yeah he's [ __ ]
hilarious how do you know this concludes
the historic 41st episode of dude Z will
and Chad have achieved a score of 77
bringing your cumulative total to 4
402. you only have 5
521 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
and then [ __ ] gets [ __ ] up in
preparation for our next episode you
must listen to Van Halen's sixth studio
album 1984. released on January 9 1984.
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the day dive collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude Z oh man that's a good album oh
that's one of my favorite albums we've
covered it good album dude yep so good
album dude Never Gonna forget when I
first heard it dude when did you first
hear it I'm gonna guess in the year
1984.
oh
and that's kind of fun we're having here
on duty
wodzen on your am eight years old I
believe uh at the time we were living in
Great Bend Kansas and my dad I remember
took me over to one of his buddies house
God if I if this name is right I don't
know Dave holste I think was his name
and he had like a Hi-Fi system and he
played it on there that's the first time
I heard it that we've covered this on
the show that and uh Weird Al Yankovic
in 3D were my two first cassettes oh wow
I'm a year older than you I was nine
years old and that um still one of my
favorites I'm so happy that we're gonna
be listening to that yeah we're about to
get into our patreon segment here if you
want to join us it's patreon.com
thank you guys so much for uh hanging
out uh and all that good [ __ ] uh
subscribe to everything support our
sponsors and uh another thing you can
put on there with mustard
yeah yeah you can put markers or maybe
on bonus segment this week will and chat
must watch and react to a video
submitted by Dr FBI if you would like to
suggest videos for Will and Chad to
react to you can submit links in the
dude Z is listening channel of the doozy
Discord access to this channel is
granted to everyone in the patreon
jumper tier if you'd like to access this
bonus segment join us at patreon.com
dude Z now will and Chad please enjoy
this video from Dr FBI it's called Old
Country Buffet training video thank you
Dr FBI for this submission
Chad and will you can find and access
this video in your duty folder
you got this in your duty folder yeah
dude I got it here oh you ready yeah
[Music]
[Music]